[Música]
los fanáticos de la realeza están
emocionados por el jubileo de platino de
la reina y lo demuestran también con su
dinero por lo que las boutiques de todo
londres están sacando provecho con
productos que conmemoran los 70 años de
reinado de isabel segundo
en ese momento estamos vendiendo muchos
de estos platos puedes ver a la reina y
ella baila te saluda cuando hay luz es
una reina que funciona con energía solar
y vender light camp son sedantes o la
power feeling
la reina es la más vendida superando con
creces a otros miembros de la familia
real
su majestad el símbolo de todo lo
británico para millones de turistas
comunal desde que estamos en londres
estamos buscando algo que no tenemos
ahora mismo estoy buscando saleros
la mayoría de los productos no están
avalados por el palacio de buckingham
pero otros si tienen el sello de
aprobación real algo que se refleja en
el precio de hecho la propia reina
supervisa algunos artículos como la
vajilla de porcelana para conmemorar su
jubileo cada pieza está hecha
minuciosamente a mano por artesanos
locales
hay un gran resurgimiento del made in
england y nosotros somos decididamente
una fábrica artesanal todos los miembros
de la familia real incluida su majestad
lo apoyan el té de la tarde también
sirve para celebrar el jubileo pequeños
pasteles que representan las joyas de la
corona de la reina y sus sombreros sobre
mousse de naranja incluso el carruaje en
el que viajará
esta capa superior de postres es la más
espectacular gachas
av
me encanta como han pensado en cada
elemento de la vida de las reinas white
el jubileo de diamante de la reina en
2012 supuso unos 145 millones de euros
en ventas de merchandising su platino
promete aportar unas ventas aún mayores
como dirían algunos dignas de una reina